okay from bell rumi on facebook i feel
overwhelmingly disheartened by humanity
i'm generally a happy person and laugh
all the time and still do
but i find myself wanting to get
evangelical about stuff i feel
passionately about
but when i do understandably i feel like
no one wants to hear it
what can i do to abate these feelings of
powerlessness and fatalism
about the future of humanity and the
planet
a little light question for you yeah
right i feel you bell roommate
oh yeah we are um i'm empathetic to the
melancholy
yeah i understand what that feels like
um it reminds me of of something i
tweeted a long time ago that seemed to
connect with people which was something
along the lines of
if you're breaking paradigms you can't
you can't really expect people to
applaud you for it
like the mainstream is not going to take
kindly to your you know counter
programming
it just doesn't work that way right so
if you're trying to do something
different if you're
stepping outside of what is considered
to be
standard operating procedure people tend
threatened by that and they're defensive
around it and they're not necessarily
going to celebrate you or
accept you for that choice and that's
just part of it
it's not personal right so the first
thing i think is
understanding that this is not an attack
on you personally
and people who don't want to hear it
from you
are really saying more about themselves
than they are about any choice that
you're making
and i'm also reminded about the life of
john lewis like this is a guy who
basically has been spent devoted his
entire life to
butting up against the system to express
what he believed in
knowing that he was only going to move
the needle a little bit but it didn't
matter to him because this was his truth
right so
if it's your truth it shouldn't matter
and i think you need to just be clear on
what your values are
and focus on leading the life that you
want to lead
and step outside of any expectation or
desire
or need for anybody else to approve of
that
and certainly uh from you know free
yourself from the need to convince
anybody that you're right in there
and you're wrong because that's a recipe
for
the fatalism that you're currently
experiencing it's like to be the change
versus
trying to to get people to change right
there's nothing wrong with activism i
mean i'm a big
i mean we need activists but sometimes
there's a limit to what you can do in
terms of person to person right
yeah so live your life live your
truth feel free to express that
but create a healthy boundary between
yourself
and any expectations you have that
you're going to be convincing anyone
else to
do anything differently than they're
already doing and i think it's important
to to uh
to always lead with compassion and love
and understanding and that's another
thing that john lewis
stood for right he's not coming from
a place of anger and frustration and
judgment
no that never works for anybody so to
the extent that your
advocacy or what you're trying to
express to other people about your
choices versus their choices
to the extent that that is tainted with
some level of judgment or
sense of superiority uh that's
not gonna work right no no one wants to
hear it for a reason because nobody
wants to be told
that they're doing it wrong or no one
wants and people don't want to be judged
so
you have to just live your life live
your truth and
the sense of powerlessness or fatalism
emanates from this attachment that you
have
to other people changing right control
the controllables all you can control
is your behavior what you're doing and
your reaction
to the world and to the extent that you
can be more mindful
and more present and more responsive and
less
reactive the happier you're gonna you're
gonna be as guru singh always says
less emotion more devotion didn't we say
that the other yeah the other day on the
podcast yeah
i'm always thinking about that right
more devotion less emotion
yeah and um and all i can say is if you
think people don't want to hear about
biodiversity try telling them a swim
story sometime they won't bother you
ever again
about a swim run race see how that goes
try to give them the blow
you're going to love it
[Music]
you